so this movie actually came out very
recently on video on demand so I was
able to watch it on my playstation 3 I
download it straight from the
PlayStation Store and I thought to
myself this is a lars von trier movie
and it's about sex addiction probably
you shouldn't make any popcorn for this
one nymphomaniac Volume one that's right
there are two of these my review for the
second one is going to be coming very
soon this film was directed by Lars von
Trier and star Charlotte Gainsbourg and
stellan skarsgård this movie starts out
with her she's in an alley she's beaten
up she's laying there and stellan
skarsgård finds her and takes her into
his home and in an attempt to explain
what happened to her she decides to
recount her past life to this man and it
turns out this is a very long story
she's gonna tell and she basically
explains her entire youth ever since she
was a little girl discovering her
sexuality and the fact that she could
never get enough of it and everywhere
she went she always wanted more she
wanted to meet more men she was always
looking for new experiences and
sometimes this really hurt her as a
person as well as others and we get to
see her past life and all the various
things that she went through as a sex
addict or as she calls herself a
nymphomaniac not heard a lot of things
about this movie some good some bad
Lars von Trier is a controversial
filmmaker he tends to make a lot of
movies that get people angry and upset
and get people talking but he is a very
good visual director and I've always
admired his craft for filmmaking even if
I don't always agree with some of his
viewpoints as a person he definitely
knows what he's doing behind a camera
and he makes a really good looking movie
here with nymphomaniac and actually a
very interesting movie a kind of
light-hearted film at times and a film
that was darkly comical while also
giving a lot of really interesting
viewpoints about humanity and I actually
really enjoyed nymphomaniac Volume one I
thought it was very well acted
especially the main present story where
Charlotte Gainsbourg is telling her tale
pistol and skarsgård these two
characters I really enjoyed their
interplay they have a lot of really
interesting things to say about the way
humans work like they have this entire
monologue about what it means if you
choose to cut the fingernails on your
left hand first or your right hand and
it actually is very interesting one of
the coolest things about this script I
thought was that the director likens
sexual addiction or the art of looking
for people to have
with two fly-fishing there's a lure you
have to wait a long time you have to
pretend that you're a certain way to try
to catch that fish and then eventually
you get to eat the fish and that's the
way lars von trier likens the hunt for a
sexual partner whether you're looking
for someone to be with romantically or
just for a fun night that's the way he
views it in this film and it was very
interesting the way he tells the tale
how's the actual craft of the movie
there's a lot of different things he
does with this film that I thought were
very visually intuitive he puts a lot of
numbers and texts on the screen and it
helps you remember some of the points
that he's trying to make as a
performance I thought Shia LaBeouf did a
very good job in this movie he has a
British accent that he does an okay job
with there are times when it disappears
and turns into an American accent
generally when he yells or gets angry
the accent kind of fades away and you
can tell that he is trying to maintain
it but overall I was very impressed with
this performance I thought he did a good
job in the movie although he doesn't
really have that much screen time the
big standout - volume 1 is definitely
Stacy Martin who plays the younger
version of Charlotte Gainsbourg
character she has to do a lot of stuff
there is a lot of sexual activity in
this film and some of it is very graphic
and a lot of people have complained that
it borders on pornographic I have to
strongly disagree for one reason
pornography is meant to entice the
viewer it's meant to make you feel a
rouse it's supposed to be erotic the way
this film handles it is not any of those
things in this film it's the exact
opposite of that it's in no way enticing
to me it's very disturbing and it's kind
of hard to watch sometimes because
you're realizing this character is just
going on a downward spiral but honestly
this feels like a very accurate
portrayal of what someone might go
through if they had this type of
addiction because none of it really
seems all that enjoyable there are some
times early on in the character's life
where she seems to be having fun but as
her life progresses and she can
continuously not be satisfied that is
when it starts to get hard to watch and
nymphomaniac was a film that had a lot
of cool things to say about the way
people operate and had some really cool
interesting ways to relate common
everyday things like fishing to sex I
think it's a very good looking movie I
think it's filled with great
performances and although it is kind of
hard to watch it's definitely a film
that I think film fanatics who are
interested in the art of filmmaking
should check out so that's my review of
nymphomaniac Volume one
to give it a B+ my review for vol 2 is
coming soon I will let you guys know
what I think about that film very soon
as always guys thanks very much for
watching and if you have seen this film
let me know you think of it or lars von
trier other past films
thanks so much and as always if you
liked this you can click right here and
get stuck Benoist